Welcome to the explainer, where we break
down big ideas into clear, actionable
insights. Today, we're digging into a
really powerful framework for
understanding why so many of us are
dealing with chronic health issues. So,
here's what we're going to cover. We'll
start with what's called the sickness
paradox. Then, we'll trace the problem
back to the gut blood connection. See
how blood sugar adds fuel to the fire.
And then, and this is the best part,
we'll explore a universal strategy that
puts you back in the driver's seat of
your own health. And it all kicks off
with a very modern paradox. Okay, so
let's dive right into that paradox. I
mean, think about it. We have
specialists for every single part of the
body. We've got incredible drugs,
unbelievable technology, and yet as a
society, we just keep getting sicker.
autoimmune diseases, skin problems,
metabolic issues, they're all
skyrocketing. So, what is going on here?
Well, the source material for this
explainer from pharmacist Benfox
suggests a pretty radical shift in how
we think about this. Instead of seeing
dozens and dozens of different diseases,
he says we need to grasp one core
principle. The body has a generic way of
breaking down. And this is absolutely
crucial. What this means is that
conditions that seem totally unrelated,
you know, like psoriasis,
musculardrophe, Hashimoto's, they're not
actually separate problems. They're just
different symptoms, different flavors of
the same fundamental breakdown in the
body's biochemistry. Okay? So, if the
body breaks down in a generic way, the
next question is obvious. Where does it
all start? Where's ground zero? Well,
according to our source, the answer
isn't where most people are looking.
According to pharmacist Ben, the main
point of failure isn't in your joints or
your skin or your thyroid. It starts in
the gut. In fact, he says that there is
no chronic health challenge out there
that doesn't involve what's called a
leaky gut. And this breakdown happens in
a really clear four-step chain reaction.
First, processed foods start to damage
the super delicate lining of your
intestines. This creates tiny little
holes which allow stuff like undigested
food, bacteria, and toxins to literally
leak directly into your bloodstream. And
from there, this contamination travels
everywhere, getting dropped off in
different tissues and sparking a massive
inflammatory response. To really help
you picture this, the source uses a
brilliant analogy. Think of your
bloodstream as this pristine, clean
lake. Well, a leaky gut is like a sewage
pipe that's been rerouted to dump all
its waste 24/7 right into that clean
lake. And this leads to a condition the
source calls dirty blood. It's a really
important concept. This is the state
that comes before any cellular disease.
The blood itself becomes toxic and then
that toxic blood gets delivered to every
single cell, tissue, and organ in your
body. Basically setting the stage for
that breakdown. But you know, a leaky
gut is just one part of the equation.
There's a second equally powerful factor
that really creates the perfect storm
for chronic illness. And that second
factor is something called dislycemia.
It just means dysfunctional blood sugar.
Now, we're not talking about full-blown
diabetes here. We're talking about the
state of metabolic stress that almost
everybody in the modern world is
experiencing. You know that feeling, the
constant spikes and crashes in energy.
That's it. Okay, let's just look at the
difference here. On one side, you have a
healthy metabolism. It's fueled by whole
foods. It's in what's called an anabolic
or building state. It gives you stable
energy for cell repair. But then you
have dislycemia that's fueled by
processed carbs and sugar and it creates
a catabolic or breaking down state. It
leads to inflammation and basically
starves your cells even if you're eating
plenty of food. So you see how this
comes together. It's this brutal one-two
punch. You've got toxicity pouring into
your blood from a leaky gut. And at the
exact same time, your cells are being
starved and inflamed by messed up blood
sugar. This is the knockout combination
that's behind that generic breakdown we
talked about at the start. All right.
So, if the problem is generic, what
about the solution? Well, it stands to
reason that the solution should be
generic, too, right? And this is where
things get really, really empowering. It
completely reframes the solution. We
shift our focus away from a specific
disease label and instead move toward a
universal strategy to restore the body's
fundamental systems. It doesn't matter
what your diagnosis is, the road back to
health addresses the same root causes.
So, what does this universal strategy
actually look like? Well, the source
material breaks it down into five core
pillars. The first two, fasting, and
using an elimination diet, are all about
lowering the body's toxic burden. And
the next three, supporting digestion,
stabilizing blood sugar, and using
strategic supplements, are about giving
the body the raw materials it needs to
finally rebuild. And you know what? One
of the best parts about this approach is
you don't have to wait months to see if
it's working. By doing something as
simple as keeping a food diary, you
start to connect what you eat with how
you feel, often within just 24 to 48
hours. That real time feedback puts you
back in control. You go from feeling
helpless to feeling totally empowered.
Okay, let's bring this all home with
what is honestly probably the most
important piece of this entire
framework. It's a fundamental shift in
mindset. The whole philosophy here is
built on one core idea. We have so much
more control, so much more power over
our own body's chemistry than we're ever
told. We've kind of been conditioned to
think of health as something that just
happens to us, something that experts
manage. But this framework says no way.
We have immense power through our daily
choices. So ultimately, the goal is to
stop playing whack-a-ole with symptoms,
whether that's a skin rash or joint pain
or fatigue, and instead go straight to
the source and fix the underlying
machine. You're no longer just managing
a diagnosis. You're actually correcting
the two systems that went offline,
digestion and blood sugar. And that's
the final question this explainer leaves
you with. It's a pretty simple question,
but answering it honestly for yourself
could change absolutely everything about
how you approach your health. Thanks for
digging into this with me.